foreign
the three Muslims today we're joined
with a very special guest sister omukaka
who we had literally two nights ago
how's it going
let's go
is just getting set up inshallah he will
join very soon for anyone that missed
the live stream that we did with her and
two other sisters from about two days
ago make sure you watch that that is a
that is a must watch a lot of gems in
there inshallah but today inshallah
we're going to be talking about a full
Guide to the modern day in the cat
getting married Four Women today Muslim
women specifically to the Muslim us
um before we go into it sister do you
have anything that you want to address
[Music]
definitely want to say again this is um
a great time to donate to a turkey in
Syria uh don't forget about this don't
get burnt out I know it's difficult with
all the pictures that we've been seeing
the videos that we've been seeing but
this is when the omanitsu most so
inshallah try to like you know somebody
said that this is the best time to empty
out your savings like this is the time
to give so and shall give freely and
trust that it will not decrease your
wealth
alhamdulillah that was a beautiful
reminder guys we already have a link in
the in the description box for a
donation for charity to relief please
hit that up every dollar accounts
inshallah and this is this is definitely
something that's that you're gonna spend
money on and it's only gonna make you
richer in Allah as the sister said so
with this being said
um the walls are also important aside
from just money if you can donate keep
uh keep doing money to us
um and inshallah we'll get through this
now first things first with regards to
this topic
um when it comes to the modern day
marriage you hear a lot of
heaviness on this topic right and I
believe that it's led by almost this
Western sense of
um pressure when it comes to marriage I
think that when you look at Hollywood
when you look at the media they almost
place like this
over-the-top dramatic seriousness when
it comes to marriage like it's it's a
lot of commitment but when you look at
Islam you know we understand mentioned
that the difference between Halal and
Haram is two witnesses that's it so
Islam it's not necessarily something
that is difficult it's not something
that is grandioso
um so why do you think a lot of Muslim
women despite that still have some type
of heaviness towards marriage
I mean I think you're totally right I
think the permanence of it is one thing
that scares a lot of people but actually
the permanence is the most beautiful
part especially I think from a female
perspective
um because men are still like you know
poligenous by Nature so there's a little
bit of thought but for women there's
nothing more beautiful than being tied
down to one man honestly having a man
and having a husband that you can trust
100 that you can submit to 100 and you
sign off your life too in a way
basically obviously after Allah is the
most beautiful thing like it brings you
so much Sakina it brings you so much
peace it brings you so much like you
know uh Baraka in your life actually so
but it's again just Western brainwashing
basically because you have to remember
the West wants to basically uh use you
and make the most out of you so if one
woman is married to a man that's it
she's she's not available for anyone
else basically
um and the West doesn't want that like
they don't again that attack on the
family home basically the structure
because families make up societies and
if a society is strong if a community is
strong how's the government going to
control you
um
that is very important I didn't even
think about it like that subhanallah
um and I think a lot of Muslim women are
beginning to realize that because to be
honest and the more you get to
understand
the most of my psychology you begin to
realize that deep down ifitra is intact
she actually wants kids she wants to get
married young she wants all these
traditional things but it's almost like
this front that she has to put up you
know what I mean and I notice this a lot
more with women than men I know they're
going to come at us but the reality is
that as men I found out that regardless
of how people perceive us we tend to
stand by what we believe in more but
women just because of the way that Allah
has designed them they're a little bit
more conscientious of what their peers
think so it's if the status quo is let's
say we need to be valuing every one of
all different ways of life and thinking
and ideologies then that's what we got
to do you know what I mean they're a
little bit more softer when it comes to
that and may Allah bless them for that
but deep down they still have the same
values as a Muslim should but they just
don't project that
mm-hmm that's true so even me personally
actually it's funny because so I got
married at 20 right but right up until
20 literally I was always
um like you know I was basically
focusing on like my education I actually
graduated and literally got married like
the next week
um after my bachelor's and but even
until then like whenever I would have
conversations with my professors or my
like you know peers and stuff I would be
talking about oh yeah I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna be a
neuroscientist because I I have a degree
in Neuroscience so I was just talking
about oh these are the labs that I'm
looking at and these are the labs that
I'm going to be joining and all this
stuff basically so you're right even I
was falling for that peer pressure even
though I knew I was about to just get
married and sit at home comfortably for
the rest of my life basically but it's
really hard to it's really hard as women
to
um just accept and kind of give into the
federal when literally the entire world
basically is telling you to do the
opposite and telling you that the only
thing that's pretty Worthy is if you're
a career your woman
subhanallah Allah I didn't even know you
you studied Neuroscience Miller bless
you for that and at the end of the day
seeking knowledge and all this even in
secular Sciences there's nothing wrong
with that right but we need to
understand our priorities anytime we do
these things at the expense of what
Allah ordained for us in rights and
roles and responsibilities that's when
things get a little bit techy but if we
can find that balance and understand
where to put our priorities in life in
this Dunya in this short life I think
will succeed that way and Allah makes
that you know promise to us very clearly
um so this being said let's go right
into it around me do you have anything
you want to address
thank you I don't even really know what
we're talking about to be honest today
we are talking about a full guide to
marriage for the Muslim all right this
is just for the Sisters mainly but the
brothers can I I guess learn some game
on this too inshallah so first thing we
want to talk about inshallah is before
it even gets to marriage right because
marriage is is something that you know
once it gets there it's a big commitment
and it's not that big of a commitment
right but it is something that requires
some level of footwork before you get
into it so um
why don't we go into some of the basic
things that you believe a Muslim a
sister should have down pat before she
even considers marriage
I mean I think it's pretty again with
the over emphasis on waiting until
you're ready I don't like that that
concept but I'm not ready yet I'm not
ready yet why are you not ready I know
people that are 26 now because I'm 20
um I'm in my mid-20s I don't want to
give away my age but basically I already
have two kids
um and P I know people my age who are
still saying that they're not ready but
they're not realizing that they're
literally wasting their potential like
um don't put too much emphasis on
getting ready for marriage but there are
some basic things that you should
um emotional maturity definitely is
important um you have to and emotional
maturity also like you're going to learn
that as you go as well but I think the
most important thing is having like an
open mind basically and be willing to
learn like have you have to be able to
accept that you're entering this
marriage
with your husband as a leader so once
you're entering once you can accept that
if you have that down that's really all
you need because he's he's going to be
inshallah we'll get to how to choose
like a husband who's a proper Amir
basically because that's also really
important but once you do that then it
becomes like you know then you're just
following in his footsteps basically
you're following in his guidelines and
but you have to have the humility and
you have to accept prior to getting into
the marriage that you have this
intention to be led basically so I think
um having that mindset is important but
other than that really basic things like
I mean if you don't know how to cook you
can learn to cook uh cleaning I don't
know anybody who doesn't know how to
clean like it's that these are super
basic things so I don't think we should
be over complicating marriage with a
bunch of like long uh boxes that you
need to take tick off before you are
ready for marriage
girls you've heard it here first it's
actually very simple let's not
complicate things but for a lot of the
sisters that say oh I don't want to cook
I don't have to clean who said I got to
do all this what would you say to that
um I think if you're okay I think okay
if you don't do it who's gonna do it
because you're living
um you're it depends on the kind of
arrangements that are made between the
husband and wife right yeah I'm not
totally against women working I mean I
definitely didn't prepare for myself if
you're doing it for fun go ahead
um but again women working there's so
many problems with that basically
because it kind of puts you
um it puts you in your masculine
basically and I would try to avoid that
um in as much as you can to maintain
your femininity uh to make it easier for
you to be a good wife honestly because
um when you start earning when you're
contributing financially to the
household women
um because we weren't really made for
that Allah made uh the husband the
provider so when women try to play roles
that were not meant for them it messes
up the Dynamics of a relationship that's
what I believe
and this is key around me I'm sure you
agree with that a lot of people don't
know about that but when it comes to
women that are you know in work and in
careers they are in their masculinity
way more than their femininity even to
exceed and Excel in these higher upper
echelons of Academia in work in career
it takes a certain amount of
disagreeability right and on top of that
their bodies weren't designed for this
level of stress too
um when you look at a man when you look
at his hormonal cycle with his
testosterone it actually Peaks early
during the day there's cortisol it's
it's built perfectly for this work life
for this this career or whatever he
wants to do but when you look at a
woman's cycle which is more monthly it's
it's necessarily not developed for her
to be out here grinding 24 7 hustling
during the day it's it's just not
designed that way and and I'm not saying
women can't do that because clearly it's
proven that women can but this
discussion was optimal and what's not
optimal
exactly exactly I agree
alhamdulillah so this being said let's
say that she has all these Affairs in
order
um one last thing I wanted to cover on
before she considers marriage is let's
say she has issues right let's say she
has baggage or she has some type of you
know unresolved mental stuff from her
childhood whatever you can call it what
do you think she should do with these
types of things do you think that
because this is not as easy as I don't
know how to cook let me watch some
YouTube videos or let me ask my mom how
to cook this is stuff that she could be
bringing into the marriage that could
sabotage it
um that she deals with so what would you
say to that
so I think one thing to understand is
that as human beings we are all flawed
right nobody's perfect nobody's coming
in with a total like you know uh perfect
mindset and um able to have zero package
everybody has some level of baggage
basically but you're right and you do
end up and women especially we have a
problem with self-sabotage almost
um so things like that if you are
dealing with uh like you know like maybe
you have some kind of past uh and you're
worried about that carrying it into your
um marriage one thing I would say is
look Allah said that once you repent
sincerely it's gone it's over it's
erased literally right you're not going
to be if you really repent from it and
if you change your ways and you don't go
back to it then that's basically a Race
So we have to also kind of have that
mindset and be willing to forgive
ourselves in a way and just make up your
mind that this is a new beginning this
is a totally a fresh start uh you can't
you can't go going into marriage with
preconceived notions about oh uh in the
past I was treated like this by men and
this is uh this is the same mindset I'm
going to be entering a marriage with
because those men that you had those
experiences with they were different
they're not your husband your husband is
different
um it's not the same guy at least I hope
you're not marrying the kind of guy that
would treat you like trash which again
we have to talk about how to vet the
right guy basically
um but yeah just don't let uh one thing
is obviously to avoid all of these
things to begin with right because I
think that's something that
um The Red Pill Community kind of talks
about a lot too like women with baggage
and women with trauma why would you want
a woman with trauma it's it's easier for
like you know to uh it's easier to marry
women that are kind of fresh in a way
you could say I guess
um and it's because of this so first of
all try to refrain from
um like you know too many interactions
with the opposite sex because uh that
will affect how you see your husband but
if uh what's in the past is in the past
you can't change it right and if you've
had now this um kind of Enlightenment
basically and you're not like that
anymore and you're trying to change then
uh give yourselves a Grace and
understand that you can be different
that you can change uh the past you
can't you can prevent the past from
carrying over into your future you are
worthy of goodness in your future have
good expectations uh not just from men
not just from your future husband
inshallah but also from Allah trust that
if you're making an effort for Allah's
sake that he will take care of you as
well he will give you good he's not
going to try you Allah doesn't want to
test you unnecessarily Allah doesn't
want to cause you pain so there's also
that element of having to work basic the
um along with trying not to let like you
know past uh preconceived notions like
affect your future relationships
um this is key because how many how many
of us men and women both we we beat
ourselves up and we can't even forgive
ourselves for what we've done in the
past and for the things that we've been
through and we we close ourselves off to
the idea that we do deserve a good life
and we do have a happy ending you know
what I mean
um so this being said there's there's a
comment that subhanallah I know me and
Nami are about to get heated but before
we've been going if you want to address
this uh I hear this argument a lot what
about
isn't she a businesswoman wasn't she a
career woman wasn't she a boss babe so
to speak what would you say about that
was not a boss Babe by any uh standards
um that's offensive to even imply uh she
did she did conduct business but again
she did that through men
um she didn't she wasn't going out and
trading herself she wasn't surrounded
and she wasn't standing in the
marketplace
um shoulder to shoulder with men the way
that women have to be Nala especially
like you know in an office setting where
you have to compete basically and it's
like you know all these things
was not doing that it's okay for women
to have businesses it's okay for women
to have incomes but again there's some
uh some careers that are better than
others so there's some business uh like
you know online business is not you can
literally run it from the comfort of
your home uh alhamdulillah and there's
many practicing women I know who are
doing that while also totally
maintaining their femininity in the best
ways and their amazing lives and they're
uh you know they're just able to have
that proper concept of like you know my
husband is still the provider hands down
like there's no question about that I'm
just doing this for
um you know my own fulfillment or some
extra money sure and it's not it doesn't
have to uh just because you're working
doesn't mean you have to be like you
know assertive doesn't mean you have to
be the dominant one doesn't mean you
have to wear the pants in the
relationship at all
yeah and if if someone if a sister wants
to take
as an example you know that's not a
problem in and of itself but take all of
her as an example don't just isolate one
thing and then run away from the rest
you know yeah she had a business and um
the prophet sallam and other men would
go conduct that business in the world
for her but at the same time when the
personal son would come back she would
have the house tidy clean quiet and she
would have food ready for the profit so
listen you know so if you have some kind
of business given that Halal online or
something no problem but as a mother you
still have children you still have the
house you know
um and I'm not saying you know cleaning
and cooking is only for the women
because there are instances of the
process would do his own chores and
stuff as well it was not to say it's
only on the women but there is a huge
responsibility for the women when it
comes to tidying up the house when the
man is out of the house because he's
physically not even there to clean so
right um
some people some people are wondering
well you know that brother slingshot
that did his shadow with us on the chat
they're like oh did you actually convert
did you do this he did like let's leave
it to Allah he did a shahada with us he
didn't join the stream because we were
having technical difficulties but still
a Muslim bro slingshot don't don't read
the comments but alhamdulillah today we
are going to have another brother each
other that wants to take the child
towards the end of the stream and he
will join us and show Allah so this
being said I think both of you made very
brilliant points regarding that to
clarify that so there should be no
misinformation anymore regarding the uh
using
as a as an escape goat to basically say
you know what therefore I can have a
career I don't have to worry about my
family this is this is foolish this is
delusion
um so this being said let's move on to
uh since we talked about some basic
things that women should have in order I
think the last thing we should look at
before vetting a man and worrying about
marriage is what are traits of a woman
that men find desirable that she should
try to embody
I think agreeableness is probably the
number one top of the list basically
um how willing are you to be led in the
relationship how willing are you to
listen to your husband
um when he says like you know when he
says things that maybe don't even make
sense to you because uh one thing that
um that happens sometimes is the woman
says oh yeah I'm sure you wouldn't ask
me something that wouldn't make sense so
of course I would listen to you why
would I not listen to you no but see
it's not it shouldn't be your obedience
shouldn't be dependent on you agreeing
with him that's not how obedience works
and there is obedience to the husband
it's different obviously from obedience
to Allah but there is obedience to that
husband as well so
um and it it will there will be
instances where you won't agree with him
where it won't make sense to you but
even in those times you have to that's
when your obedience is really tested if
you already agree with him then what's
the big deal in you doing what he says
basically that's that's you just doing
what you wanted to do anyway
so
um having this having
um agreeableness basically being humble
um and willing to like you know just um
like acknowledge that he is the leader
this is really super important I think
and that's what's most important to men
because men
um they have this in their nature where
they are the leaders and they they need
to be respected and that respect is
going to be tested when you don't agree
with him basically so
um if you're and then the other thing I
would say is one thing is learn to hold
your tongue basically
um and this comes with time uh inshallah
but also just try to like you know work
on like just because you're triggered
just because you're upset with something
try to not bring it up immediately don't
talk it about if because if you jump
into it immediately you're so you're so
upset that you end up talking about it
in a way that comes off as very
disrespectful and rude uh even if you
didn't mean to come off that way even if
you
um were just sad it comes off as angry
basically and these were issues that I
used to have even at the beginning of my
own marriage I think this is something
this is a bit of a learning curve
basically uh where I he would be like
why are you so angry and I'm like I'm
not angry I'm sad and but it comes off
as rude when you're trying to so uh
learning to like you know hold your
tongue a little bit sometimes and be
patient with the way you approach your
husband and the way you talk about
sensitive topics basically give them a
heads up like you know so just uh I
think these are all traits that men uh
generally really appreciate
um because it helps them be in control
it helps them feel like they are the
leader basically and then it helps them
be better leaders too uh this is how you
get because also the more feminine you
are the more masculine your husband will
become basically the more agreeable you
are the Kinder you are to him the more
his love will go for it for you and the
more he will be willing to provide for
you as well so it's a bit of a give and
take it's a two-way Road basically
hundred percent I agree as a man that I
mean what do you think
my bad uh yeah I agree 100 percent
um it you know it's a dynamic for a
reason and um as soon as one and
actually I think
a lot of the time it's the men that slip
up you know and it's the man who refuses
to be masculine and then the the woman
has to step up and and take that role
sometimes you do have the case where the
woman is trying to just you know compete
with the her husband and push him out of
that place but I think from what I've
seen majority of the time the guy just
does not want to take on tasks himself
he doesn't want to do the DIY projects
that his wife is asking him to do around
the house he doesn't want to take out
the garbage he doesn't want to do these
things
um he's tired or whatever excuse he has
and then the woman's like okay you know
what screw it if you're not going to do
I have to do and that starts questioning
her into that that like what people say
masculine frame or whatever
fellas you heard it here first don't
think we're not coming for you there's
no diffusion of responsibility in men
either because when it comes to men we
are the leaders we are the maintainers
we are the protectors if we really are
leaders we can't expect women to just be
feminine willy-nilly by default you need
to set that example and that polarity so
she can rest into her feminine in the
first place yeah I want to say this
clearly I think most of the problems of
women or with women or women problems or
mental problems with women most of them
would be fixed if men were just like
proper men we would not have feminism we
would not need feminism if men upheld
the rights of women if men actually you
know like would beat the living life out
of a guy who transgressed against a
woman we wouldn't have we wouldn't need
feminism we wouldn't need these horrible
social constructs that are created these
horrible laws that are created around
you know protecting women if men would
just stand up and do the job right uh
for their wives and their their
daughters a father would rather lock his
daughter in the house than have to take
her out because she needs to be
protected when she's out like just take
your daughter out for God's sake you
know take your sister out take your wife
out
um you know life is not supposed to be
within the kind confines of a little box
there is one thing that I didn't want to
address and this is a very important
point I notice this a lot in the daisy
communities they want women to work they
want women to be educated they want
women to be kind of sacrificing
themselves these men are their youth a
lot of them are in this so yes what
about if the man wants the woman to have
a job and make money in addition to them
like they they basically tell her this
is what I want from you I need you to
work I need you to be super educated if
you don't have a PhD parents care a lot
about the stuff in in Arab and some DC
households as well I don't know why and
these women these men have no hurry up
whatsoever
um so what advice would you give two
sisters like this aside from the common
sense advice that don't even get into
these marriages to begin with
um but let's say they're already with a
man that's kind of like that
this is where something is
um
oh sorry go on no go on
okay I was saying um I think you're
right so okay I agree education
especially is pretty important to me as
well
um so for example for me personally
right speaking from personal experience
my parents said that you have to have at
least a bachelor's degree before you get
married so what I did was I I knew I
wanted to get married earlier I didn't
want to wait super long so I
um I took classes in the summer too to
speed up the process so I actually
graduated typically people graduate um
by the age of 22 but I graduated at the
age of 20 basically and I was able to
get married at 20. um so there's ways to
work around like you know these
um these uh expectations
um sometimes uh now as for um working if
he wants you to work well I wouldn't
personally I would never marry someone
like that why would you want to marry
someone who
um wants you to work when that's his
responsibility his responsibility to
provide it's not on you at all I
understand now it's getting more
expensive and oh if you want a certain
lifestyle at like you know all that
stuff
um if he asks if he asks nicely maybe
okay you can contribute here and there
but if it's the kind of guy that says no
100 you have to uh this is like you know
like a contract basically where you have
to spend 50 uh as well and you a 50 of
your money goes to the rent and blah
blah I don't think I don't think that's
a marriage you should be entering at all
because that's not that's not a man if
he's not willing to provide for you
I agree with 100
this being said and there are some other
things that I did want to mention as
what the sister did mention about things
that men find attractive but as a woman
before you get married at least do your
best to get on as much as possible
obviously marriage is one of those
things that you kind of have to just
take and learn as you grow there are a
lot of things that you can't have
paralysis by analysis you can't delay
for no reason and Dean is one of those
things it's a lifelong journey but this
being said there's some basic things
that you could do right now if you're
single in the process to just get
straightened out if you're not working
on your five daily prayers please do
that right now this should be first and
foremost for the sake of Allah not for
marriage but understand Allah will place
in your marriage so indirectly it will
still help you in your marriage aside
from that I'm trying to enjoy good for
bit evil trying to unlearn a lot of
these toxicities and Cancers that you've
learned ideologies this type of stuff
and inshallah then you will be ready for
marriage so let's say now you have a
sister that's finally prepared for
marriage
um whatever that means because I think
there is no perfect time uh what are
things that she should look for in a man
well I think uh I think there's a Hadith
there is
um when a man comes to you and you are
happy with his religion and you are
happy with his manners uh marry him and
those are the only two criteria I
believe that you should put at the
Forefront yes there's other things here
and there but that's really that really
sums it up I think a hundred percent
um so that's one thing and the other
thing yes uh I think um you can look for
of course magic Lifestyles and all this
stuff but you have to realize money
comes and goes honestly and as a Muslims
I'm really not for the whole
materialistic lifestyle
um I understand enjoying money but I
believe it should be in your hands not
in your hearts because we know that some
of this hubba were the richest man
um but they uh they were able they still
died with like barely anything on them
basically because uh they didn't have
like you know the effects of richness
basically so I don't think
um I think this um uh this pursuit of a
stable man and like you know uh oh he
has to be earning this much or oh my
mother has to be this much basically
um this is uh kind of even sometimes
delusional honestly like I think you
guys might have seen um there's like a
delusion calculator or something like in
the west like you know because even
Western women now they're like oh he has
to be making 600k
um do you know how many men in America
make 600k uh like probably like one
percent are you a one percent do you do
you even realize how many men even more
than 80k 90k
it's ridiculous exactly
exactly so just being a little bit
realistic with other things like you
know that's really important but really
look if you find someone
um that has good religion uh if he has
Dean in him he's going to be very
careful about your rights because he
knows that he has the answer to Allah so
when he knows uh when he knows that he's
going to be careful about how he
provides for you he's going to be
careful about how he treats you he's
going to be careful about respecting you
and all literally everything and what
more does a woman want really and when
you have somebody with manners it's like
you know that's the best thing on the
planet like it's this is this is really
all you need trust me women at the core
we don't really care about money I don't
think uh right now obviously most of us
are brainwashed by like you know the
Western World to need a certain level of
like materialistic lifestyle but you can
have all the money in the world but if
your husband doesn't respect you or if
he disrespects you in front of someone
else for example even just once the
amount of pain that that would cause you
would make all of his wealth be
equivalent to dust for you like it would
be there would be no point of any wealth
so be sure that you choose someone that
is uh that is has good Dean and has good
mannerisms don't compromise on these
things and the way you get a man like
that is again like what you said about
being like you know make sure you're
praying your five daily prayers because
uh in the Quran Allah says
um
like you know the the evil men are for
the evil women and the good men are for
the good women like that basically I'm
paraphrasing I think but uh the concept
of like you know uh and this was one
thing that I really focus on too
actually before getting married
um I was I had this mindset where I was
like okay I'm just gonna focus on myself
actually and become the best Muslim that
I can possibly be and I want to have in
me every single trait that I would want
to have my husband so if you don't want
your husband talking to other girls make
sure you're not talking to any guys and
and this is actually a really important
topic
um inter intersex relations basically
like uh between genders between the
opposite genders that's another
important topic that you have to make
sure you two are
um
yeah I definitely think that we should
we should talk about these these uh
issues like because I think that these
issues that that come after marriage or
or during the marriage itself they're of
utmost importance but I did want to make
sure not to cut you off the the Hadith
that you were mentioning I wanted to
finish the Hadith too
um that it says that if a man does come
to you for marriage with religious
religiosity and party that you marry him
or else corruption will spread in the
Earth
and the reasoning behind them is why
else like why would you not marry
someone like that that has that
religiosity that character that Dean
that taqwa but now combine that with
what you're saying about all the things
that women find desirable in men right
not necessarily the money but the
security because money is equated to
Security in their minds I think that her
having a level of physical
attractiveness to the man is important
too
um can you go into that a little bit
briefly before we go on because some
women and this is the way that parents
raise them sometimes they place an over
emphasis in Dean which is fine no one's
saying that's a bad thing right but
let's say the guy has kind of let go of
himself in the Dunya and they're just
expected to force that desire on her
which it really doesn't work that way no
that does not work that way
um no so I think one key point to this
is also when for women right I think one
of the most attractive thing about women
is actually their youth like a Young
Bride um the Beauty and the Noor that
she has
um is totally unmatched by an older
bride honestly
um so one thing is make sure make use of
even if you're honestly even if you
don't think that you're super attractive
even if you don't think you're the most
beautiful girl on the planet and you
deserve a really attractive man who
works out and is fit and it's totally
like you know handsome tall whatever
everything that you require
um make use of your own uh Beauty and
the most beautiful thing about a woman
is her youth firstly and also her
character
um and I think you can't realistically
expect people to marry you without being
attracted to you either for men or women
um no matter how religious you are even
me uh I love my husband to death
obviously his character and it's like
you know Dean is the primary um the
primary things that I focus on but I
married him because obviously I was
attracted to him like if I wasn't
attracted to him I would not could not
have married him to be honest because
um marriage is also made so that you can
lower your gaze right if you're married
to an attractive man then that's going
to help you lower your gaze I think my
husband's the most attractive man on the
planet like I literally don't need to
look at anyone else nobody else can
match uh his standard basically because
um because I married someone that I'm
attracted to and this it goes both ways
too like for men as well uh you can't
expect them to marry someone that
um they're they're not attracted to just
because she's super religious or you may
have wonderful traits and but and also
obviously beauty is in the eyes of the
beholder just because uh you're not
attractive to one person like you know
sunsets are pretty but so are fairy
lights you know so uh those two uh just
because you don't look like a certain
image of beauty that you have in your
mind or a certain image that Society is
pushing doesn't mean you're not
beautiful fairy lights don't look
anything like sunsets but they're both
beautiful to look at
wow anything you want to add to that
um yeah
um just look past you know the
superficial stuff because there are
things that will make you attracted to
him that don't have to do with his
appearance
um and unfortunately I think women are
being encouraged to go down the route of
oh he looks like this and he has these
characteristics and other women probably
find him attractive and focus more on
the day in day out aspects of life you
know is he a strong-minded you know
well-behaved well-mannered person with
upright character and morals you know
are they someone who I'm gonna feel
protected by because he could be the
most you know gorgeous man in the world
but run away and leave you you know in
front of the Bears
so these other things you have to look
at how protective is he you know how
caring and and providing is he and if
he's not willing to you know uplift his
own mother and and sisters and family
and those around him then you just
should know that he's not going to do
that with you in your marriage you know
if you can tolerate that okay but if you
can't then no it's not going to go well
because he will very very very quickly
become the ugliest person and you'll be
wondering I how could I ever even you
know give myself to this person I can't
believe I found him attractive for a
second
hmm yes the other thing I'll say is
attraction grows in a marriage it really
does like sure um I found him attractive
in the beginning as well but the way
that I view him now has changed actually
from the beginning like still like so
Allah remember that Allah prays places
so much Baraka in a Halal relationship
that can't compete with any boyfriend
that you've ever had that's given you uh
he might have been the most handsome
person in the world but trust me your
husband is going to have a different
appeal if you do it for the sake of
Allah for the right intentions and if
you marry a religious man because really
the you'll experience uh the attraction
the physical attraction the obviously
attraction to character as well all of
this it grows in a marriage um when you
marry a righteous man who has good
character so again those two things
absolutely
so somebody asked is 30 too old to get
married do men find a woman in her 30s
more attractive and then someone
commented we will be 33 in Jannah I
don't believe that's all at all so I
think that's a false equivocation and uh
sister do you want to go into that
um women being 30 I don't think there's
any problem with that I think
there's men that are 40 looking to get
married like you know there's there's
there's so many people in the world like
I think sometimes we cut ourselves off
from a lot of opportunities and we're
stuck in like you know just this one uh
little neighborhood that we live in
almost basically
um uh and or nobody finds me attractive
in this neighborhood but just Branch out
look for other options if you even if
you've quote unquote passed the age of
marriage or something uh that doesn't
mean all hope is lost by any means
whatsoever
um so yeah there are men that actually
even find actually older women
attractive too uh so that does exist and
uh there's hikmat in that basically
because obviously not everyone is going
to have the means not everyone is going
to have the opportunity not everyone is
going to have
um the guidance basically maybe you were
like you know messing around in your
early 20s and you just didn't know any
better for any reason maybe you didn't
have a Wali that could have guided you
maybe like you know there could be so
many reasons that you didn't get married
in your crime so if that has happened
for whatever reason just remember that
whatever's happened in the past doesn't
mean that you're doomed never the
believer is never doomed the believer is
always hopeful because you have Allah on
your side and Allah has no shortage of
good to give his Believers so uh like
you know you have to have good
expectations from Allah and Allah is as
his Believers think of him
alhamdulillah so we need to make sure
that yes we do encourage women and men
to get married young and as soon as they
can but obviously at the same time if
it's delayed there's no there's no harm
it's still possible but
um some people are like women in 50s
this is a very important topic because
understanding this that fertility does
decline after 30 a lot for women and we
need to understand that sure Allah Allah
is still the one in control of
everything including you basically
conceiving so no one's saying no one's
going against that but we got to be
realistic too if you want to have let's
say six kids and you're with a woman
that you get with let's say she's 35.
the chances of you even getting her
knocked up once or twice
is very low probability and there's a
lot of complications that come so for
six if that's your characteristic we
need to be realistic but the point that
we're trying to say is prevention is the
best cure there should be no reason
someone unnecessarily Waits the song to
get married but if that is the case then
there's no harm in that and if you rely
on all inshallah Allah will find your
way out inshallah promises in the Quran
um so this being said we can finally go
into the actual vetting process so how
should women find these men where should
they find these men because women we
understand that women shouldn't
necessarily be on social media
that's a difficult one but um it doesn't
have to to be difficult I think
what was that sorry you got cut off no
no so I'm saying women women are
obviously and men too are encouraged to
not be talking too much to the opposite
sex on social media uh free mixing this
type of stuff putting themselves in
situations with the opposite gender
where they can interact where they can
get to know one another
um so a lot of women commonly ask where
do they find this man
um so the first thing is definitely
utilize your mahrams right that's the
first thing you have to
um ask you that and ask your dad
um your brothers might have friends
basically that if your brother is a good
good guy basically like a good religious
person then he'll have religious friends
too that like you know might know some
even if you don't marry your brothers
friends basically they will know other
people basically
um so there's all these things there's
all these Avenues
um Plus on top of that
um you know social media I yeah you
obviously don't talk to the opposite
gender on social media but a lot of
people actually get married on like
through literally Instagram
um or like uh through social media
because
um we are co-existing in this space
right so you do know that there is this
uh there is this person basically but
um again the way that you go about it
has to be totally Halal and you have to
make sure that you know you're not
falling into it like uh overly obsessive
or anything like that if you see someone
if you're following someone on Instagram
right for example and you think oh you
know he actually he seems religious he
seems kind he has a great relationship
with his family
um maybe like he and he seems like he
would be looking for marriage uh you can
have your brother literally message him
on Instagram and just ask there's no
harm in asking people love to give the
example
when it comes to you know the boss babe
example but she also did she did
approach uh like you know through her
friend kind of uh so there's nothing
wrong with women also approaching
um men in that way through Halal means
um and it's better if you have somebody
in mind that you're following and you
think first of all I don't recommend
following the opposite gender actually
but if you are and you know of this
person then just ask and that way
um it won't be you won't be like you
know in the gray area and you won't be
oh I wish oh I wish or maybe maybe one
day
um no just ask and get it over with
because either he's going to say yes or
he's going to say no if he says no then
it's over stop having feelings for him
basically online and if he says yes then
congratulations you you you can get
married
okay so what would the next steps be now
in in terms of vetting
so I would say when it comes to
get it's definitely important to have
one
um I don't believe in marrying blindly
just because like you know just based on
what you've heard from people or just
based on what you've seen on social
media yeah we uh yeah girls think that
they are the best like you know stalkers
basically and they can figure out his
entire life trust me you don't know
anything so
um that's one thing and what I would say
is um you know make sure that you're
that a guy is also betting him one of
your mahrams because men talk different
to men he might be able to like you know
sway you off your feet he might be able
to Woo You like by it like you know
through his charm but that charm is not
going to work on your dad your dad
doesn't care how
um like you know how he uh gives like
looks over his shoulders or anything
um but you might fall for that so uh
it's important to get your image
involved um if your mahrams are not
willing there's a lot of sisters
unfortunately that don't have a very
helpful uhms
um some someone in the community that
you can look up to you might have an
uncle you might have an older cousin you
might have uh the Imam of the Masjid
literally
um you can go to these people and ask
for help don't be afraid to I think
women are so shy and we're so uh afraid
to approach people for help that we end
up like you know harming our own selves
don't be afraid to ask for help and get
people involved do not absolutely do not
try to do this on your own that's the
worst thing you can do because again it
leads to so much more fitna it leads it
opens you up to being like you know used
really
um by the men because there's so many
cases of like you know secret marriages
and this and that there's just so much
um that you have to watch out for so
definitely get responsible uh religious
men involved from the very beginning
alhamdulillah okay now the last thing
before marriage is going to be red flag
so as a woman what are things that you
would want to advise these women folk
these sisters about red flags and a man
um so red flag uh the one thing we
talked about right where he wants you to
contribute financially to the house
that's a huge red flag because that
means he's not ready to be a provider
um don't marry someone who's not willing
why would you give yourself to a man uh
as a wife why would you give him such a
precious gift uh of being his wife to
someone who's not going to take care of
that gift and not give it its rights so
you are a gift as a woman so
um but also don't like you know don't
hype yourself up too much because that's
the other problem nowadays we're so
hyped on our own selves
um so also stay humble but still like
you know don't uh don't don't settle for
men that aren't men basically
um when you see someone who has a strong
personality basically that's a really
good uh that's a good one
um also check his relationship with his
mom actually because uh the way that he
interacts with his mother can tell you a
lot the way
um he interacts with his siblings what
are what are his um how is he viewed by
the community what does the community
think about him basically there's uh
there's a lot of things another red flag
um if he's broke that's not a red flag
that's one thing I'll say
um not always this is a disclaimer Yes
Men uh should be uh like you know men
should be driven men should be
um you know they should understand the
responsibilities of financial but not
everyone is like you know making six
figures uh every year or like you know
anything even close to that so
understand that just because he's not
super wealthy doesn't mean that he's not
a total Gem and that he can't become
also give space for men to grow right
because if you're marrying young for
example then he's probably also not that
old you wouldn't want to marry someone
with a huge age Gap necessarily not a
lot of women prefer to do that
um so he uh give him some Grace too like
realize that oh he might be at the
beginning of his career maybe he just
graduated Maybe he's still like you know
if he's still living with his parents
that's not even though the Western
Society like you know
um just looks down uh so badly on men
still living with their parents but it's
um again there's so much that goes into
it how expensive is for example in the
area that he's living in maybe he lives
in uh like California I can tell you it
costs a lot
um versus if you move to some place like
you know on the East Coast rent is
cheaper so
um just because he's living with his
parents in California it doesn't mean he
can't afford an apartment in Georgia
like for example so there's a lot of
things to kind of consider so I think um
but yeah red flags definitely if he's
not willing to provide
um
what's something else maybe you what do
you guys think actually from the male
perspective I think indecisiveness in a
man is a big ground of concern any man
that is very hesitant and he doesn't
know how to lead because whether you you
consciously trust him or not on a
subconscious level you don't trust his
authority you don't trust his
discernment and that's only going to
lead you to subconsciously resent him
over time in the future and put yourself
to where the big boy pants and be in
your masculine energy
hmm Romy what about you any red flags
that you want to advise these sisters
about looking out for in men
um I mentioned a few of them before you
know
um just
focus on his character and Dean like
you're gonna you're gonna have to pay
attention to the subtle things you know
how he speaks with people how he treats
people how he treats the waiter at a
restaurant that you uh him and your
father go to you know like uh if he tips
the waiter like I'm not saying hyper
focused on small things but notice the
small things and then you'll get a
bigger picture of who this person is
um sometimes it's it's easy to get you
know to get lost in oh my God you know
he has this and he has that and and then
you you forget literally every single
other aspect of his life
so um focus on those things inshallah
and how he treats those around him his
character his Dean how fast he is you
know to want to pray Salah if you know
you guys are saying let's pray and he's
like oh no let's wait or something like
that
we're not we're not we're not
entertaining the delusion in this in
this stream as well like oh if he's
under six feet don't even look at him
none of that like how do you control
someone obviously women find taller men
attractive women find better men
attractive in any regarding any Avenue
in any confound or variable but it's not
something that's as important as you all
think at least in the go far World
um but one more thing I would do on a
definitely in this conversation is
if you have a man that is emotionally
reactive
this is something that is a huge red
flag and this is not to say that I'm
reactive men don't deserve good women or
don't deserve to be happy in life but
this is something that is a huge grounds
for concern because as a woman you don't
want that in a man you don't want
someone that you come to as an emotional
storm and he's just gonna make things
worse he's arguing with you he's
bickering with you 24 7. he's coming to
you complaining about things 24 7. and
this is just reality I'm not saying men
don't do this but women don't find this
attractive so you'll find this and it's
it's definitely something that's an
overbearing extent that he's very out of
control with his emotional intelligence
and just his emotional estate this is
this is a huge alarm like this should
should not be something that you just
let go of and think it'll fix itself or
it's okay he does this once in a while
once a day once a week no this is
something that he needs to get in check
and most people don't fix these things
um most people don't want to fix their
problems and they're shortcomings so
it's better for you to find someone that
doesn't in the first place
uh but we'll start there's one more
question
what do you recommend about talking
after proposal before engagement should
call or phone call be allowed
um to be honest I'm not sure and I think
you should ask a scholar I have heard
different things but um I'm gonna
refrain from answering because I
genuinely don't know I I know the the
general practices is that you should
have uh the Wally present and I even
know that there's an instance where the
process
I believe is Apostles he spoke with a
woman where in public where people could
see them but couldn't hear them
um so Allah again just go ask a scholar
uh I think there is at least a
difference of opinion on this best
practice to have the the brother and
father present though alhamdulillah
um before we move on there is one more
thing that we got to keep in mind that
and this is not advice to someone
specifically this is just advice to
anyone looking for a spills make sure
that they're honest how many people lie
and we know that they lie again the
truth always comes out to the light but
we're like you know what we justify it
like oh maybe it's a white lie maybe
they didn't mean like that but somebody
that lies about small things like that
for no reason what makes you think
they're not gonna lie about big things
that they could justify and these things
will catch up over time because it rules
about their character and integrity or
should I say lack of Integrity
um so this is one more thing uh is there
anything else you guys want to add to
the red flags before we move on
no I think we're good on that okay well
there is one more thing I want to add
laziness if you have a man that doesn't
want to be a hard worker he doesn't want
to go the extra rounds he doesn't want
to he doesn't have a mission or purpose
in life right this is something any
sisters on and I was like do you care if
a man has a degree do you care if a man
has this qualification do you care if a
man earns this one a lot of them I would
say a vast majority 95 of the sisters
that I've spoken to they all say one
thing I don't care about that what I
what I do care about is that he has a
purpose a direction in life he has a
goal he has a mission exactly something
that he wants to achieve in this life
not that he's just complacent and weak
and he'll try to figure it out because
he could have a PhD in astrophysics and
just be sitting in his ass at home not
doing anything in life have no ambition
no purpose but he could be someone that
completely Started From The Bottom
doesn't have money but he has that goal
he has that ambition and he puts his
money where his mouth is he walks the
walk he doesn't just talk to talk and
over time the results will speak for
itself
100 so what you just described is also
actually something I lived basically
um I think marrying a man with purpose a
man with a direction is absolutely
essential because uh even if he's not
like my husband wasn't the richest guy
when we met basically but uh he has like
you know he had his goals he was
actively working towards them it takes
time and you know it's a beautiful thing
actually supporting uh being the
supportive uh role basically in a man's
life while he builds his Empire
basically like
um a lot of women unfortunately nowadays
uh they just like you know if you're how
are you gonna how as a man are you
supposed to succeed and build an Empire
when you're a queen is basically just
eating away at it and taking away from
it either through bickering or like you
know uh useless spending and all this
stuff so like being patient and really
um really like serving uh the husband's
purpose and serving his goal is a one
wonderful wonderful thing to be a part
of like it is so fulfilling when you see
your husband's goals like come to life
it is the best thing ever and if you
find a man that has a purpose even if
he's not there yet even if he hasn't
achieved his goals if he's working
towards it if he's if you've seen him
that he can
um he uh really wants it badly basically
and he's willing to put in the effort
then
join that join join the Caravan
basically and become a part of that
because
um that adds so much purpose as well to
your own life as well and it's really
fulfilling I think
alhamdulillah okay so one last question
from the live chat before we go on to
the actual marriage itself and inshallah
this can definitely be a multiple part
thing it doesn't have to be that we talk
about everything today
um but the question is the sister asks
advice for black Muslim women seeking
marriage please how can we deal with
racism and I'm not going to say the word
here uh of us may Allah help us all
um okay so racism is definitely I know a
huge huge problem but you know
um
and also the fetish aspect of it is also
exists but
um there are you know I would say make a
lot of Dora first of all because that's
the first that even when things don't
make sense to you if you're making Dura
consistently
um Allah will make away from you from
where you never even imagined basically
so that's one thing make sure that
you're uh consistently making love and
you're asking for the right thing
basically uh second I would say
um don't
um I don't know I'm not
um I've been pretty privileged with that
so I can't really relate to that but I
would say Dua is the number one thing
and
I don't know that's a tough one what do
you guys think
Rami what do you think is this like in
regards to they have it or someone else
has it or the I'm assuming they are the
black Muslim uh that they were talking
about and the experience racism uh being
objective
yeah I mean just the The Fetish part
because sister
I I remember I remember you mentioned
like fetish or something like that
um and I wanted to
address that because so long as it's
something that's Hala there is no issue
but I want to know are they talking
about they have it or the other person
has it
no I think they're talking about the
other person having it but you're right
actually if somebody has a fetish as
long as it's hello there's nothing wrong
with that you're right so even if there
is
um because she mentioned two things she
mentioned racism uh and she mentioned uh
basically people having uh not to say
the word but people having a fetish
basically for uh black Muslims
oh I see okay okay so specifically for
um
I mean okay firstly on the first part
um unfortunately there's not much you
can you can do about that I was in a
position once where I wanted to marry
someone who was from a different uh
ethnic background than me and I was
rejected just because I wasn't from the
same place they were from uh so it's
unfortunate it sucks but
um if you have a family who has that
kind of mentality you don't want to
marry into them you don't want them to
you know just allow you in you want them
to love you and accept you so even if
they you know let you in and let you
marry this person you're gonna have a
horrible life with these kind of in-laws
so it's unfortunate it sucks it's gonna
be like a worldwide cleansing that we
have to do
to make sure we get rid of this you know
obviously racism and also anything
that's against reverts and those persons
just accepted Islam and you know stigmas
around that we need to really work on
the ummah to get rid of these
um and to go back to what the prophet
peace and blessing be upon him you know
told us because all the sahaba you know
basically all of them were reverts
maybe there's a few that were basically
born into a Muslim family you know like
maybe like she when she grew into
maturity she was under Abu Bakr and the
prophet sallam so uh but most of them
they you know were were rebirth so
um I would say for the first part of the
question just you see any hint of that
walk away stay away and you will find
someone who is a good Muslim who has no
worries about that insha Allah and then
for the second part
um I'm not one to judge right I'm not
black so I can't really say anything I
think if someone had a Palestinian
fetish um I don't think I'd have an
issue with that I'd be like yo I'm the
perfect role for you
um let's get married so but that's
completely up to you as long as the
fetish or whatever is halal
um it you know it's good
one other thing actually I want to bring
up is um you have to remember also our
brains we have something that's called
the negativity bias so every time you
have a negative experience you're going
to remember that way more than you're
going to be open to any positive
experience basically anything that
reinforces a negative uh idea that you
have in your mind that's going to stick
in your head a lot longer and it's just
going to reinforce a negative image
basically but trust me there's a lot of
people now alhamdulillah there's a lot
of people that don't have uh these kind
of racist uh mentalities so be open to
that be receptive to that have good
um have good expectations trust that
again having to work the law as well and
make Dua for it because these people do
exist there's many alhamdulillah people
that don't like you know there's many
families I know personally honestly that
don't care about these things basically
and it's not just oh uh or like
overlooking it it's they it's you being
black wouldn't be something that they
just have to kind of put up with it's
actually something that they don't like
you know it's not a negative thing at
all so those families do exist um
there's many interracial couples that I
knew obviously in America like when you
grow up in America like there's so many
uh alhamdulillah interracial marriages
and all this stuff uh just because
Melting Pot and everything with all
sorts of cultures and ethnicities so um
and a lot of them are successful but see
again if you go back to that Hadith of
rasula where if she uh if she looks for
a man who has religion and manners
because once you have religion you're
not going to be racist how could you be
racist uh as a religious religious man
as a truly religious person so
prioritizing those things and uh like
you know just making sure that you are
like you know because you also kind of
attract what you are in a way so making
sure that you don't have like you know
um anything like you yourself are also
the kind of religious person that you
want to attract so making sure that
you're like you know praying praying
five times a day is just the basic uh
basic criteria we really uh these are
basic for I that we shouldn't really
have to remind ourselves but I know it's
tough like
is at a sad state right now but
um
you know just try to be uh super
religious and you'll find a super
religious guy and religious guys don't
care about racism basically
guys if you made this for It's shahada
Time alhamdulillah spam Shah all the
time in the comments section in the live
chat right now and if you love this
episode let us know what you think in
the comments inshallah we will do an
episode on actual how to be a proper
wife in a marriage inshallah this one
was just leading up to the marriage
itself the guide to getting married
Insha'Allah and we will continue this
inshallah
assalamualaikum Jonathan how you doing
bro good brother how you doing I'm the
LA bro doing well uh do you want to put
your your camera like sideways bro I got
you I didn't know what you guys would
prefer but here we go there we go
perfect bro tell us a little bit about
yourself man before we come in uh I'm
30. I live in Boston Massachusetts
um I was raised my mom is Cape Verdean
straight from the island the Christian
woman grew up in a Christian house
you know I did my thing as a kid an
American lifestyle and um you know we
all go from
believing in God to atheist and not
believing and you know just saying he's
not real and I think everybody goes to
that always comes back around eventually
you know what I'm saying to understand
there is one true God and I've just been
through a lot lately man uh I have a
beautiful family I got two beautiful
kids
um
I've been dealing with just my trying to
find who I am my spirituality for a long
time looking through all the religions
and then I stumbled upon Islam maybe
like I would say like a year ago and I
started really doing the research and
everything it just everything just made
so much sense to me and I even brought
it to my buddies and we go over it
together and we've been
we've been going over everything bro the
Sumerians the pyramids the Egyptians you
know once you start going down that hole
it's like crazy but
it attaches it's all there bro it's all
there it's a beautiful thing um I'm like
this is this is huge for me it's really
huge if you know who I was if you were
my friend you would understand this is
really big um
I'm trying to get closer to God I'm
trying to do the right things
and everything in that Quran is just
speaking to me so this is big for me and
I'm like I'm mad emotional right now
before my girl's like you're ready you
ready I'm like I could tear up right now
you know this is this is beautiful it's
really beautiful I'm the love bro Miller
bless you we just got some last minute
questions for you just to make sure that
your beliefs are in line with being a
Muslim so if you have any questions let
us know now and then I can ask you the
questions inshallah
no no you can you can go ahead okay and
then we'll talk a little bit about your
journey after all right so yes sir I
want to give you that time and the
platform to speak and and Inspire anyone
else that might be on that brink of
making that decision that you want to
but perhaps they just have some doubts
or anything like that they're
misconfused about um so the first thing
is do you believe that there is one God
worthy of worship that God is one I do
okay do you believe in God sending
Messengers to mankind I do okay do you
believe in Revelation that God has sent
to these Messengers I do do you believe
in angels that Allah has used to send
Revelation to The Messengers I do do you
believe in the day of judgment
I do do you believe in Divine decree and
predestination from Allah I do okay I
love me bro did I miss anything
no you're good alhamdulillah okay with
this being said brother romy's going to
put in the shahada in Arabic and English
insha Allah
um so we'll just wait for him to do that
okay perfect so we're gonna read it on
Arabic first and then we're gonna do it
in English all right okay okay so
I do and LA
Anna
Anna muhammadan muhammadan rasulu
I bear witness I bear witness that there
is none worthy of worship that there is
none worthy of worship except Allah
accept Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness that the prophet Muhammad
that the prophet Muhammad is the servant
is the servant and messenger of Allah
and messenger of Allah oh
my God thank you guys
this has been such a like a long journey
for me bro for real
I can't hold it together but it's all
good he's a tears of joy bro I'm sorry
to do this on the live but I've been
through a lot of a lot of stuff in my
life and this means a lot for you guys
to do this for me I appreciate it I'm
like I've been watching you guys God's
work is not easy bro it's not for the
week and you guys are doing great work
out here bro keep on keeping on I'll put
you on to my other buddies and you know
they're gonna be they're gonna be here
soon as well they just need a little bit
more of affirmation but um yeah we're
doing this bro thank you I appreciate
you guys go into this please go into
your story man
oh man my stories we we don't got enough
time for my story but uh I'll let you
know on a little bit um
I worked I worked you know regular drug
products Warehouse blah blah blah and
then I was making like 24 an hour you
know I'm saying I had a kid already
um payments all around and uh I made a
decision one day to say I I quit I just
quit because I'm an artist I do
photography I went to college for that
and I said I just quit I didn't go in
the next day and I just said I needed to
chase a dream that was about like six
years six or seven years ago I went
through the bottom bro my like I was
late on child support laid on all my
bills laid on everything but I kept
pushing I did not want to go back to a
nine to five to work with somebody else
and God willing bro everything worked
out beautifully and the more bro the
more that I was in tune with my
spirituality and getting closer to God
the more everything cleared up for me
even
and and just happen even better and
better the closer I got her to God it
put more confidence in me to keep on
going it and like we're here now so now
I quit the job I run my own guitar I do
real estate photography for I've been in
Boston magazine a couple of times now uh
I flip houses
um I'm about to sell this house I bought
I don't want to give numbers but we're
doubling up on this flip which is a
beautiful thing I gave my mom money I
gave my sister money it just like and
this all just happened like we are at
the peak of this so like this this all
just happened within the last like month
you know that I came up on this my dad
had a seven family he wanted to sell it
um
he didn't want to sell it I convinced
him to sell it because with the money we
could have done great things and right
now we're doing great things mom's happy
dad's happy sister's happy the kids are
good I'm good I'm in a nicer home nicer
environment everything's good my
business is great you know everything is
looking up and like this is the last
step for me right here this is the last
step so I can continue being as rich as
possible back in the day I smoked I
drinked and now I just I tell everybody
not to I tell everybody not to clear
your mind to make sure you're focused
because one drop of alcohol one smoke of
the weed it Alters your mind you can go
from being one person
right now I can be one person right now
go smoke a joint and have a hundred
thousand percent different thoughts
right away and that is dangerous so
it's just a beautiful thing I'm glad I
did this I've come so far like and like
I can't wait to like share this with my
children I know they're really young
right now and I can't like fully grasp
you know God and all this stuff but like
we're gonna do it I'm gonna I'm gonna
show them the Quran and show them the
way
of Islam and I have a girlfriend I do
have a question
I have a girlfriend uh we're not married
we have a child together
um
she is not a Muslim yet but she is going
she she wants to be you know so maybe
she'll be on this live soon but I was
just confused a little bit like I don't
is it for marriage or like now that I'm
Muslim and she's not how does how does
that work
so I think it's best that we talk more
in depth after the stream just in
private about this but
um what's her belief I guess she a
Christian is she atheist
she was like an atheist like um not
believing I wouldn't say atheist I would
say like agnostic like believe there was
a high power just didn't know what where
to pick she's seen me go through this
now I mean she watches all the videos
with me she's right here with me now so
she's yeah she's on the same path she's
on the same path she she understands it
um I would say she's 99 there I think
this right here is the one percent she's
gonna need to fully give herself I see I
see and that's a beautiful thing and I'm
glad that you know you could be an
example for those around you I think
it's a very beautiful thing and we're
very proud of you may Allah blessing
bless you increase you inshallah we're
going to be here for you I would say no
worries inshallah um the way to go in
Islam is marriage you know no matter
what no matter who you are what
situation you're in and it's to preserve
of the rights of both you and especially
the rights of the woman you know the
rights of the wife and the sister in
this situation so
um once she's you know able to accept
Islam
um you know have her accept Islam she
could do it with us or with anyone else
and then getting married is very easy
right you don't have to do any long
drawn out process it doesn't even
necessarily need to be
um done and recognized by the state to
be recognized in the site of Allah
um and like I said we could talk about
all this afterwards all you need to get
married are two male Witnesses uh
someone to conduct the ceremony a bridal
gift you're going to give her a gift you
know money or whatever you know she
asked for
and
um with her father's permission or you
know someone someone of uh of uh I guess
status you could say in her life but uh
in this case I think because she's just
accepting Islam it might be like the
Imam or the leader of a mosque so that's
really all you need okay sit down for
half an hour go through the ceremony and
then you guys will be married
sounds good
things stop moving fast bro things start
moving fast but um I'm ready I'm ready
for this bro I'm ready I just
this has been a crazy experience for me
man like so this is a beautiful thing I
cannot wait to just dive deep or do more
research and just really do the work
like now I feel like I can I can do the
work and I am like in my group I am the
person that everybody looks to like so
when they see me do this trust me
there's gonna be a lot around who will
question that they're gonna they're
gonna get into it so a lot of people
around me can't even believe I'm doing
this to be honest but um
you know like like like it said the
truth is there it's not for some it's
not to be convincing somebody else it's
like if the text is written you know
what I'm saying you gotta read it the
truth is in there and that's what I tell
everybody I'm like just open it up just
open it up and read I don't have to
explain it's all explained in there
literally yeah
there has to be no convincing this is
not like we know when you see like
Christian missionaries and trying to
like really get in your head bro yes yes
we can we can refute doubts and and
things that don't align with reality but
I think the truth is already there the
Quran is the thing that is if anyone
comes into it with an open mind they
don't need anything else
um they will create a group chat
inshallah with me brother Rami on her
and you any other private matters we can
discuss there but I do have one last
question for you what would you um
answer to the brothers and sisters that
are kind of wondering I want to become
Muslim but I have way too many way too
many desires way too many things that
I'm caught up in and these are unislamic
things
um I would say if you're caught up in a
bunch of stuff that's not righteous or
doesn't feed your good into your soul
and
the moment you realize that the path of
righteousness is the path that you
should take your life will become better
no matter what even if you don't become
a Muslim right away the path to become
Muslim is an eye-opening and spiritual
experience in itself I would say for the
people who are like struggling with that
open the book up read it do your
research even do read the Bible read
everything and then read the Quran it
will be so clear to you and it's in
times of spirituality you definitely
don't want to put toxins in your body
whether it's drinking whether it's
smoking whether it's
crazy you know s-e-x whatever you guys
are doing
it's all you wake up with a guilt when
you wake up with that guilt that's how
you know it's wrong everybody's got
those voices in their head that one that
says yo do this do this do this it's so
easy to do the devil's work and it's so
hard to do God's work but what what
comes from hard work you go to the gym
you never nobody wants to go to the gym
you pump those weights but you look you
look Godly you know what I'm saying you
look you're looking like a a huge guy it
sucks it's hard but you get the results
and it's the same thing with this if you
put the work in with your spirit and
your spirituality and you do what is
right you will reap the benefits at the
end no matter what and before me even
doing this like I've just been trying to
connect with God so much and he's just
put things in my
every piece has lined up perfectly with
the thought of righteousness positivity
and having God is who want to guide you
through everything will line up and
that's that's coming from me somebody
who don't Came From The Bottom who don't
been through it all everything and I've
had I've always said I'm a guy who had
the worst luck anything that happens I
take two steps forward I take ten steps
back something always happens as soon as
I accepted this to myself
I've been taking steps forward and I've
never taken a step back from there and I
I keep I I just want to climb this
mountain and keep climbing it's
beautiful and the feeling you get from
being righteous is overwhelming when you
do good things it feels good when you do
bad things
you're gonna you will have to pay for
that at the end you will be judged for
everything that you do so start thinking
about that now and understand that that
thing in your mind that tells you yo
don't do this
that's that's what you need to listen to
listen to that and go towards that don't
go to the other thing that's easy no you
can go to the club and go to the bar
whatever whatever that's easy to do to
do this work for God that is hard bro
even explaining this to people is a hard
thing to do to come not to convince but
to educate people and to try to show
them God is a difficult thing as well
you know what I'm saying so
I would say to anybody
it's uh it's a hard it's a hard path but
it's worth it every step of the way is
worth it and at the end of it if you do
it and you race towards God you will be
the happiest person on the planet and
everything in your life will line up
perfectly 100 percent
inshallah those beautifully put together
bro
uh sister and uh brother Romy do you
guys have anything you want to add
before we wrap up the stream inshallah
the only thing I want to say is
um
subhanallah you know it it's amazing
when when someone just accepts Islam
because the prophet peace be upon him he
had mentioned that Islam forgives all
sins so you know no matter what a person
has done in their life Allah has
forgiven them for it any transgression
that they've done against themselves
against God Allah completely wipes their
slate clean and it's as if they're a
newborn baby yeah and that should be
something that is um
said more also because I bet a lot of
people who think they've done a lot of
bad they probably get scared about that
but it's like
this is your chance to be reborn like I
know I've done I haven't been the best
of persons my whole life but I know from
this moment right here on
I feel like my sins are forgiven through
this becoming a Muslim and every step
that I take from here on out I mean it
is in the step of light and
righteousness and I promise that I will
not stray away from that this this means
so much to me bro like I I just want to
explode right now because like I can't
wait to like get into it to keep reading
and to just spread the love around it's
just love is beautiful and on top of
that and on top of that every Muslim
that I have come across
it's just the nicest most I went to the
gas station the other day and uh the guy
was there and he said I was like I had
my feeds on I had my beads and he was
like oh you Muslim and I was like no but
I was like I'm really thinking about you
know converting and he was like oh he's
like you really she's like you look like
one you look like what I'm like yeah
yeah I was like yeah it's funny he's
like but no he's like you really should
he's like you know what take my number
down this is my name he's like if you
need any help with anything if you're
going through something or anything he's
like just text me we'll talk about it
bro let me tell you that right there
that was my solidifier for this because
I was like I don't even know this man he
just gave me his number tell me to reach
out to talk if I'm depressed or whatever
going through it I'm like this is what
it's about the Brotherhood The
Sisterhood everything about it is just
so unreal that it's too real and it's so
beautiful that and then besides that
it's like you don't join for you know
you don't you don't become a Muslim for
it for that it's a big part of it but
God man God is the one the one that you
need to do this for so um
I agree with that God is the one because
we all do these things for the sake of
Allah now brother at the gas station he
doesn't get money out of this bro if he
helps you if he talks to you everything
we do as Muslims as Believers is for the
sake of Allah we want to earn the
pleasure of Allah and we don't want to
earn the displeasure of Allah and
because we do make an active effort to
strive for being the best performing top
quality brothers and sisters in the
community that we can with Muslims
especially with Muslims
yeah 100 bro like and that's what I that
when I when I saw that I was like he's
not looking for no money he's not
looking I didn't tell him anything about
my life about what I do for work and
nothing he genuinely genuinely looked me
in the eyes like if you need help let me
know bro I talked to a a million people
not one person that said that to me or
have ever said that to me it took the
the one Muslim guy at the gas station to
do that you know like and it's just a
beautiful thing man and like ever since
then
it's funny like now now I see things I
saw a dude praying on his carpet like by
his car now I'm just seeing it
everywhere now that it's like you know
I'm submerged that's a beautiful thing
man every Muslim that I've met has been
so just heartwarming just loving and
want to help a stranger out you don't
know me from nothing and you want to
give me your number if you want to help
me out that's beautiful brother you know
and like I'm the same way I'm the same
way I always try to help people out bro
after I see somebody struggling I'll
handle money no matter what I'll even
offer them jobs like you wouldn't want
to get off the street you want to come
make twenty dollars an hour you know
like let's go like I'm I love giving to
people I love helping people so like
when that dude did that for me it really
like made me understand like I was like
this is for me this is for me this makes
sense
how can I not want this you know what
I'm saying like look at you guys you
guys you guys got you know decent little
following just the fact that you guys
messaged me back on Instagram like that
quickly
and then you
um how do you pronounce your name
brother but yeah when you message me
back that quickly that that meant a lot
to me too to know you I know you guys
are busy you guys are running your own
life but bam it was like that and it was
like look we're right here where are we
did it I appreciate you guys bro so much
bro for real bro Miller
in the dean
um I do want to make a quick one this is
not fear mongering Gotta Give a big
disclaimer but anyone that is out here
accepting that Islam is the truth they
know intuitively this is the reality
there's a truth there's no difference in
opinion there's no doubt about it don't
give in to The Whispers of shaytan the
whistles do not because you will get
these intrusive thoughts like oh I'm not
ready to give up this I'm not ready to
give that up I'm not ready to quit this
or quit that substance I know I got to
pay five times a day now I'm not ready
for that nothing is more important than
in the eyes of Allah you taking that
step by the non-worthy of worship except
Allah
messenger nothing is more important than
that I don't care if you do that and
continue to sin I'm obviously we
shouldn't but it's better that you take
that step and work on yourself take that
step be like you know what let me work
on with you before I take that step
because in the latter situation it's not
guaranteed that you're even gonna take
that step right right you're 100 right
and you're speaking to me like directly
with that because I came from heavy
American lifestyle bro like
drinking all the time getting hammered I
smoked a pack of cigarettes a day for a
heavy long time you know I'm I've been
quit now for like two and a half years
um drinking I literally like even even
coming up to this like I haven't been
drinking like partying every single
night you know what I'm saying but like
I I've been slowing it down but bro I've
been waiting for this because like I
know what you said like don't do it
after whatever I've been I've been I've
been doing all I can before this moment
right here let's just say that now that
This Moment's here it's all gonna happen
because I know that I can't let down my
my God and I know now especially now
that I'm here he's watching so anything
that I do and I know of it is almost
like a sin sin you know because it's
like I know that I've done now I'm a
Muslim I know God I know God's here I
know what it is I know what's right and
wrong and if I choose to do that and
knowing that I feel like it's even worse
than just like not knowing that and then
doing the sin you know what I'm saying
so that that's what's going to guide me
to stay righteous bro honestly I promote
sober mind is the best mind you know
what I'm saying you can get high off of
Love and you can get high off of helping
people and just doing this this is my
heart right here talking to you guys you
know is it feeling the love and
spreading the love that's all I'm going
to do it just being a family man being a
great father teaching my kids how to how
to be awesome and um and become
successful obviously number one too and
the love bro what a wonderful to end it
on I say we wrap it up
um unless you two have anything to say
and I don't know why bro like I have
this this deep inclination that not only
are we gonna do what we can to help you
but I see your energy as a perfect fit
for a man that can give a dawa you know
what I mean and that's to anyone not
just limiting it to anyone that doesn't
have that energy but you have that Vibe
about you that you're passionate about
it and that's something that people of
dawa need and require not to be
overzealous now not to be too much in
people's face but the perfect balance of
like having that that love for the Deen
and wanting love for other people what
you want what you want for yourself you
know what I mean you should want for
other people what you want for yourself
we're not out here keeping anything
we're not a religion that says you got
to be born into it now come on no we
gotta spread it right exactly exactly
brother yeah um bro um my energy is very
high bro like I've I've opened my mind
so so heavy you know and I'm very I've
educated myself on so many things so
many platforms I've been through so many
things I've been a bad person I've been
through so many experiences to know how
to deal with people and to really be
kind for me to be kind enough to be this
person now it's like a marvelous thing
because I definitely was just like a bad
boy you know but um yeah man I love the
energy I love I love talking to
intellects as well
um just to keep educating myself
oh no
uh-oh I believe strikes again student
mode uh there we go
did I cut out yeah your audio's a little
a little choppy though
can you hear me good no
it's it's okay it's staticky but we're
kind of nearing the end of the stream
anyway so I think we got the main
messages across alhamdulillah ah yeah no
for sure um yeah if you guys wanna
chat or whatever you guys want to talk
later let me know
um I appreciate you guys so much bro I
watch you all the time
um that kid Dawn I think that's his name
the the kid who spouting all that young
Don that was bro that was the craziest
thing that kid that kid needs some help
he needs he needs a lot he needs
somebody to sit down with him and really
and really talk to him because he's just
saying he's just saying
just just like things that you know
General statements that anybody can say
but it's like
he's lost that boy is lost though and I
can see it he's not genuine about his
own religion like you can see people
that are genuine about their religion
and they got something to say it's like
this kid I feel like he just hopped on
and he's just making like a mockery of
his own religion or whatever he's a
Christian and he's making a mockery of
of Muslims and everybody around just the
way he acts but I don't want to get too
deep into that I did peep that and I
needed to bring that up to you like that
kid he needs some he needs some help bro
for sure hopefully we can we can talk to
him one day for young Don and all the
brothers and sisters to you know Allah
says in the Quran it's not the eyes that
are blind but it's the hearts
and for this Mankind in general
inshallah
yeah with that being said about for
everyone who attended and stayed towards
the end for hashtag Jonathan in the chat
if you stayed this long and made it for
the shahada
uh sister for joining us and brother
Jonathan for joining us and taking your
shahada and with that being said
thank you